un mensaje de agradecimiento de
volodymyr selenski el miércoles por la
noche después de haber recibido una
ayuda desesperadamente necesaria está
deseo de prom los eeuu han anunciado un
nuevo refuerzo de nuestra defensa un
nuevo paquete de ayuda de mil millones
de dólares esto incluye la defensa
costera la artillería y los modernos
sistemas de misiles agradezco este apoyo
es especialmente importante para nuestra
defensa en el dogma no sólo de bomba
como producción de la nación borrón
landon vice mientras tanto los combates
en la región del donbass se intensifican
consideró de uned como punto central de
la guerra en un escenario similar al de
mariupol varios cientos de civiles y un
número desconocido de combatientes
permanecen atrapados en la planta
química asad de la ciudad los
funcionarios regionales afirman que el
panorama está empeorando con el ejército
ruso rodeando a los soldados ucranianos
por tres frentes pero a pesar de que la
presión aumenta quien ignoró el
miércoles un ultimátum de moscú para
entregar la urbe en otro lugar de la
región del donbass al menos dos personas
resultaron heridas en la ciudad de beppu
craft después de que un cohete impactar
a una zona residencial
estábamos haciendo nuestras tareas en
casa entonces hubo un estallido y todos
nos caímos al suelo había mucho polvo y
humo ya no hay casa
y de bajar
mientras tanto las evacuaciones han
continuado en el oeste del país con
muchos residentes indefensos huyendo de
sus hogares en la ciudad de europa casi
intacta y elena estaba durmiendo en su
cama cuando una explosión hizo volar el
techo de su casa fue uno de los varios
golpes que se produjeron a lo largo del
día pero a pesar del creciente peligro
ella ha decidido quedarse y
hay bombardeos por toda ucrania donde
vamos a ir tiene sentido irse si
llegamos a algún sitio qué pasa si hay
otro ataque nos quedaremos en esta
ciudad muy un tour gris
en su última previsión ucrania dice que
rusia está planeando extender los
ataques por todo el donbass en los
próximos días apuntó honduras lubiáns
desde el norte y aún treinta y cerca de
bajo hacia el sur